Ні - блокуванню Азовського моря.
Після захоплення українських моряків в Азовському морі
і введення воєнного стану в Донецькій області
дедалі більше робітників Маріупольського порту
приєднуються до громадських активістів, які
влаштовують акції протесту проти дій Росії.
Портовики вже щонайменше рік не можуть
працювати в нормальному режимі через постійні затримки
російськими військовими суден, які йдуть в українські порти.
- Блокада призводить до економічних наслідків,
насамперед для працівників
підприємств морської галузі,
які знаходяться у так званій блокаді.
Це десятки тисяч працівників Бердянського, Маріупольського портів,
є судноремонтний завод.
Після введення воєнного стану в роботі Маріупольського порту
не сталося суттєвих змін. Поки що ніхто не втратив роботу,
але в порту вже не стоять судна, як, приміром, у вересні,
а графіки прийому вантажів постійно зриваються
через те, що російські військові в листопаді
затримували всі кораблі, що прямували в українські порти,
мінімум на 5 діб. Порт двічі в цьому році переходив
на триденний робочий тиждень через скорочення
обсягів вивантаження продукції в середньому на 30%.
Відповідно зменшилася і зарплатня робітників.
Металургійний комбінат "Азовсталь", робота якого
напряму залежить від можливості морських перевезень металу,
поки не запроваджував скорочені графіки робити.
Це вдарило б по таких, як електрик Олексій Верема.
Він боїться, що навіть введення комендантської години
може призвести до скорочення персоналу,
проблем із заробІтною платнею і взагалі паралізувати роботу підприємства.
- Острах є, якщо дійсно ситуація погіршиться.
Окрім матеріального питання,
може втратитися частина замовлень.
Може початися війна, і це буде, звісно, дуже погано.
На продукцію металургійного комплексу припадає
приблизно третина українського експорту.
З Маріуполя товар відправляється переважно морем.
На цій мапі видно скупчення суден, які наприкінці листопада
не впускали в Україну російські військові.
Кожен день затримки обходиться судновласникам у 7-10 тисяч доларів.
За підрахунками експерта "Майдану закордонних справ" Андрія Клименка,
середній час простою всіх цих кораблів біля Керченської протоки
обходиться кожному судну в 70 тисяч доларів.
Ці кошти потім лягають у ціну вантажу, тобто
продукція дорожчає, і український метал
з цього регіону поступово втрачає свою конкурентоспроможність.
А це вже проблема не лише для маріупольських металургів.
- Якщо уявити собі ситуацію, що
зовсім припинився експорт
металургійної продукції зі Східної України,
тобто така сама загострена ситуація,
то  це мінус 12-13% ВВП України.
На думку експерта, уникнути таких втрат Україна може,
якщо уряд реалізує свій план щодо будівництва
нової автомобільної траси на Запоріжжя
і нового залізничного шляху в обхід Волновахи.
Громадські активісти Маріуполя наразі бачать
єдиний шанс для стабілізації військової та економічної ситуації.
- Вимагаємо місію ОБСЄ поширити мандат на Азовське море.
Підписи під відповідним зверненням
до країн-учасниць ОБСЄ в Маріуполі вже почали
збирати. Металурги і портовики, які підписали це звернення,
хотіли б також, щоб країни-члени НАТО допомогти б Україні
розбудувати "москітний" флот, аби в акваторії Азову
з’явилося більше українських військових кораблів.